اعلن ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان عن اطلاق شركه تطوير المربع الجديد
بهدف تطوير اكبر داون تاون حديث عالميا في
الرياض مشروع المربع الجديد سيعتمد في
تصاميمه على تطبيق معايير الاستدامه ورفع
جوده الحياه كما سيتم اقامه المشروع على
مساحه تتجاوز 19 كيلومترا مربعا وبمساحه
طابقيه تصل لاكثر من 25 مليون متر مربع
المشروع الجديد سيوفر اكثر من 100 الف
وحده سكنيه بطاقه استيعابيه لمئات الاف
السكان وكذلك متحفا مبتكرا وجامعه متخصصه
في التقنيه والتصميم
[موسيقى]
من مدينه لاهاي الهولنديه ينضم الينا
المخطط الحضري في وضع مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معي في النشره الرابعه من الرياض
المشروع اليوم اريد ان اسالك عن الاضافه
التي سيضيفها هذا المشروع والفرق بينه
وبين تطوير مناطق تاريخيه اخرى مثل مشروع
بوابه الدرعيه مثلا ما الذي يختلف عن هذا
المشروع
والله طلعنا على مشروع اللي اطلق سمو ولي
العهد اليوم في الواقع ان هذا المشروع من
وجهه نظري انا انه مشروع تكنولوجي عمراني
اكثر من كونه مشروع عمراني والسبب بسيط
جدا وواضح ان هذا المشروع بكون انه يستخدم
التكنولوجيا العاديه العاليه التقنيات
العاليه جدا الا انها ايضا ينتج
التكنولوجيا والدليل ان وجود جامعه متخصصه
للتكنولوجيا والتصميم هذا اهم فرق عن بقيه
المشاريع التطوير
العمرانيات اللي ممكن نتخيلها موجوده في
هذا المشروع سيد فؤاد هو في تقنيات اله
عفوا باسلوب
متطور جدا وهو الاستخدام هو الذي سيتيح
للزائر التعرف على بيئات جديده مختلفه
ومتنوعه اكثر من المشاريع العمرانيه
المشاريع العمرانيه التقليديه هي محدوده
بالطابع الموجود الطراز الموجود والطابع
الموجود لكن المشروع هذا داخل
المكعب سوف يكون
البيئات التي سوف يعرضها المكعب مئات
مختلفه ومتنوعه ولا محدوده باستخدام
التقنيات الحديثه مثل
وبالتالي من النظره الاولى للفيديو لهذا
المشروع يشبه كثيرا يعني استشراف المستقبل
مثل دلاين في في اعلان الاول ان كنت شاهدت
العام الماضي يعني اكيد انتشفته طبعا
اريد ان اسال يعني المشاريع بهكذا شكل
بهكذا تخيل
المستقبل ايضا القادم ما الذي تعنيه
بالنسبه للمدينه بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه ايضا حتى كذلك فيما يخص التخطيط
الحضري والتصميم العمراني والتراثي ايضا
في هذه المنطقه
بالنسبه لي انا هذا يعني انني انني اجلبها
واستحضر المستقبل الي الان بدل ان انتظر
المستقبل ان يفاجئني باشياء انا لم اكن
مستعد لها
طيب خلينا نروح نشوف ايضا نتوقف فقط مع
هذه
مع هذا الفيديو بشكل طبعا هذا الشكل
المكعب طبعا بهذا المشروع ثم اعود اليك
المكعب
[موسيقى]
اعود الى ضيفي السيد فؤاد مره اخرى
طبعا الشكل المكعب هنا ربما يشبه الطراز
النجده القديم في التصميم اريد ان اسال عن
دلاله هذا الشكل انت كمخطط حضري وعمراني
ويعني مهتم ايضا بهذا القطاع كيف تنظر
اليه لماذا هذا الشكل وما الذي يميزه كذلك
والله هو لفكره الطراز النجدي مثل ما
تفضلت اللي هي معظم المنازل او القصور في
ذلك الوقت كانت مكعبه ونستحضر مثلا
الايقونه بقصر الملك عبد العزيز اللي هو
المربع من الخارج تجده قصر بسيط بالوان
بسيطه بنوافذ صغيره ولكنك لما تدخل جوه
تجد ساحات وسيعه تجد اروقه بيضات تجد
مجالس وسيعه اي ان البيئه الداخليه مختلفه
تماما عن المشهد الخارجي وهذا مرمز بشكل
ممتاز في المكعب حيث ان من الخارج يبدو
سري مبنى سري لا تتوقع ماذا يحدث ماذا قد
تجد بالداخل ولكن في الداخل ستجد معالم
وبيئات مختلفه كثيره ومتنوعه يمكن قد تكون
لا محدوده فهو استحضار من التراث لكن بشكل
جديد طبعا فكره المكعب هي
تطوير لفكره منطقه الارتكاز الرئيسيه في
اي تطوير العمراني ان كان ساحه او سوق او
مجمع تجاري او خلافه ولكن هنا نقطه
الارتكاز حتكون هي المكعب
بما مع المشروع مع بقيه اطراف المشروع
اللي هي البيئه العمرانيه المحيطه
شكرا من مدينه لهاي الهولنديه المخطط
الحضري فؤاد عسير شكرا جزيلا لك